[Musique]
pourquoi est-ce que je trahirais parce
que tout le monde a un secret
il est temps de s'intéresser aux tiens
le monde ça va trop vite pour qu'on
puisse suivre ou être doublée 0,7
aide moi mon frère jacques at war je
peux confier ça
comment dans le monde vous êtes double
zéro depuis deux ans
rester sur votre fils si vous barrer la
route je vous mets une balle d'un chemin
j'ai trop bien sûr je savais que ça
collerait entre vous non
bond
james bond
alors vous n'êtes pas mort que vous
m'avez manqué
il est la meilleure source dont dispose
ce pays si vous sentez que vous perdez
le contrôle je ne perdrai pas
le contrôle
hans
tu as tout lâcher pour elle
dès que son secret remontera à la
surface ce sera ton arrêt de mort
puisque ce tu ne veux pas savoir james
bond permis de tuer
[Musique]
antécédent violent
je crois en ai parlé à mon double sauf
que vos talents mourrons avec votre
corps
les murs me survit forme l'entente
l'histoire n'est pas très indulgente
avec les hommes qui se prennent pour
dieu
[Musique]